ona - so like he was kind of like in a
low point at that time cuz he was just
like he cried at that trip yeah yeah
yeah he's at a very low point
specifically be in his career like he
knows that he wasn't doing well he knows
that he was bombing in I think when I
just to give him credit to like what I
like the bottom two
he was perceptive to criticism right
especially when the VB came in and she
kind of came in hot with some advice
he's like okay I agree with that like
and he was gonna try to work on it I
think the sad thing about Hana situation
was you know you're kind of put into the
scenario and on a reality TV show or I
don't think they realized that with this
quote-unquote Fame there's a lot of
positive but there's a [ __ ] ton of
negative that you have yeah constantly
and if you're not really prepping you're
not really ready for that mhm and you go
well I didn't sign up for this it
doesn't matter what you signed up for
when your name in your face and on your
business and your life is out there
you're leaving yourself up for the
public to judge who you are period end
of story
and it's such an organic thing that I'm
sure that you know Tara Stiles is not
gonna think oh this is gonna happen it's
just so organic how they how they shoot
this and edit it that you just don't
know what the audience is gonna think
like I've had conversations with people
to where you know um you know people
have messages mean cuz I'm like you know
I'll make a joke about somebody's
content or whatever parodies or whatever
you know what I mean yeah and there's
like oh like I put a lot of heart and
thought into that kinda sucks that you
do stat I'm like but listen once you put
your stuff out to the public eye on an
entertainment scale it's up to us to
interpret it however we want that's the
beauty and the negative part about your
art right if I put out a film right like
I didn't cook right I put that film out
and it had a 20 percent on Rotten
Tomatoes that she would hurt me right
yeah but I can't be mad for for people
for feeling that my film was shitty yeah
you put it out there so that we could
have an opinion yeah you have an opinion
it's not I could think it's trash to it
I could be upset but it's not gonna kill
me on the inside because I understand
the relationship that I have with
putting my stuff out there for the judge
though you're not cyber bullying cyber
bullying is a whole different thing
people could say oh you put it out there
so we could write whatever we want
that's different though cuz like I feel
like a lot of people what they think is
that it's like oh you're you know when
you're having that opinion of your
content the
that they provide out there they would
think like Oh because I've seen some
comments it's very interesting maybe
like dang like what if that person when
I'm a female what if that person was
your daughter why don't you think that's
like a horrible thing to say about your
daughter I was like well she kind of put
it out there like it's not that he's
hating her it's just putting an opinion
there's no it's not that it's not
empathetic right it's more like you
walked into an entertainment space and
this is what this platform is more and
it kind of sucks that nobody preps maybe
some of these classes about hey when
you're on this show understand that
these are the consequences that yeah
you're gonna get a lot of publicity but
people are gonna have opinions about you
and you have to be okay with living with
that and it's it's it's harsh it's hard
man I I feel for that girl a lot and you
know even when we were talking about her
previously on the podcast right about
like Oh like we were saying it for like
the host perspective on the show but we
also mentioned she's only 22 yeah she's
a very young person she's only making
mistakes that young people make and I
think we were trying to view her at an
adult lens of like she should know
better how she's [ __ ] 21 yeah and she
puts up this you know image of her being
strong which physically she is probably
wore out but she's very innocent the
inside I mean look at what's that deal
with she had a crush on Bo like she was
nothing but this innocent girl couldn't
stop giggling yes that's how innocent
and pure or just naive she is that any
attack it would kill her and she got a
lot of attention to a point where I saw
her does she disable comments yeah so
only her friends could comment her on
her so I feel so sorry for her like she
hasn't gone through so much she hasn't
gone through any experience nobody
nobody's really ever prepared for that
stuff like even for me you know when I
get bad comments which I get a [ __ ] ton
of them - mm-hmm yeah heat it up heat it
up but did I you know for me the cool
thing is is I trying to make it into a
game it's like how can I install this
person and make them feel like [ __ ] yeah
and then bother them for the rest of
their life
so for my part of this conversation what
do you mean
cuz that's what you do to me what do you
mean you talk back to me in a way where
you know like oh it's gonna make her
frustrated no yes you yeah no I do not
ya know I just like how you but in my
conversation well I do that because
you're doing something very bad okay so
anyway yeah she messed up recently - and
she had apologized she was so mean to me
recently and don't even go there
hey I did apologize I didn't you're
being really mean and you all you do is
keep joking and joking I don't I can't
tell any jokes or not because I'm always
serious now cuz I got no time to joke
I'm a mom yes that's why I'm saying if
we have a kid because apparently I'm the
only parent yeah you need a relax man
you say you need that chill man I get
you say baby chicken I I gotta bring it
off you gotta relax a little bit baby
why you wanted me to up my voice right
so I'm upping it I didn't mean the
intensity I just meant the volume it
comes with it yeah
but um you know in her case it's it's
it's you know it's those people are that
we I think we see a lot they kind of put
up this front that they're always strong
that they tend to be the weakest when
it's behind closed doors yeah and I
think that's why people say like hey
check up on your friends I get a little
I'll be honest with you guys if I could
have a moment honesty when people check
up on me I get [ __ ] weirded out like
they're like cuz you know they see me I
get stressed out and they're like hey
man wanna make sure are you doing okay
and the first thing and I think it's
because we grow up with like macho dads
and like watch of Korean men when they
ask me they go hey are you doing well
the first thing I would say is make shut
the [ __ ] up they're trying to just be
there for I know I'm not mad at them but
it's more like you make you feel weird
but I think you gotta you gotta you
gotta work with your heart thing no I do
work with my heart like I stressed out
and I have my ways of distressing I
appreciate it a lot but I I guess so my
dear that is you know you with your road
rage and some really the last time you
saw road rage oh actually no just your
road rage of speaking not like actually
driving and like you know if something
doesn't get delivered on time you get so
pissed about that it's
like it comes out of nowhere you're like
hi dear I did it I'm like are you
talking about yourself are you talking
about me right now yeah I think you're
talking about you right now this is her
by the way the dog does doglike things
right collapses to the floor and buries
her face in a pillow and I'm like hey yo
chill yeah you could say that because
you don't clean her poo and pee from six
o'clock in the morning till nine o'clock
at night and I'd quote what she told me
about she goes I don't want you also
taking care of the dog because I want to
talk to loved b-boys and it loves you
okay never said that yes you did because
you said yeah okay better later
you better stop lying on my gas right
now oh don't clap at me like a seal all
right don't you dare clap at me like a
seal I'll roundhouse kick you out here
are you insane oh by the way we have a
dog her name is bunny Sacramento
California right who's interrupting who
right now I think there's habits that
you have that I also have that you had
that I also have his over here doing the
same [ __ ] to me that she hates she goes
let me tell you I think you guys
information oh really
what do you sound like right now this is
so deja Vu's upping this is DejaVu s-- i
think we have a deja Vu's right now this
is crazy isn't it
see she bites dude the hypocrisy the
hypocrisy continue nice wait anyways so
why have it oh we're doing it
interrupting games again huh so we have
a dog
yeah dog's name is boonie okay her full
name
boonie bear so booty bear her name is a
pony no no no it's boonie bear oh okay
so mean so bunny bear is our dog right
and she she got so upset because when um
when I had her boonie really likes me a
lot
yeah so when we would walk she would try
to walk ahead of me with the dog but
booney would stop and wait for me to
come and so because she remembers
traumatized experienced dog like even in
additional information on that hold up
my talking yeah you'd like to interrupt